disfuncional y caótico así define un
informante el funcionamiento del
ministerio de exteriores británico en el
momento en que los talibanes tomaron
kabul rafael marshall trabajaba para el
equipo de casos especiales a cargo de
las personas en riesgo por sus vínculos
con reino unido asegura que entre 75 y
150 mil personas les pidieron ayuda
entre ellas apenas el 5% la recibió el
21 de agosto en el pico de la crisis
señaló que él era la única persona
procesando los mensajes que llegaban al
equipo desde el viernes a primera hora
de la tarde no se ha leído ningún correo
electrónico y había miles de mensajes
por leer creo que más de cinco mil y la
cifra aumenta constantemente marshall
afirma que dedicaba sus turnos de ocho
horas estrictamente a revisar
solicitudes y que a pesar de la urgencia
durante cinco noches seguidas no hubo
personal trabajando entre distintas
razones denuncia que nadie del equipo
tenía suficientes conocimientos del país
ni hablaba ninguna de las lenguas
afganas algo que se sumó a distintos
problemas tecnológicos el ex empleado
público acusa a dominique rap quien
ocupaba el cargo secretario de
exteriores en aquel momento de retrasar
varias evacuaciones urgentes resultado
de estas disfuncionalidades se tomaron
decisiones de vida o muerte de forma
arbitraria según marshall está claro que
algunas de las personas que quedaron
atrás han sido ejecutadas por los
talibanes el primer ministro británico
niega las acusaciones o phising la
evacuación aérea de kabul de 15.000
personas como hicimos durante el verano
es uno de los mayores logros militares
de los últimos 50 años
londres además añadió que desde agosto
ha ayudado a otras 3.000 personas a
salir del país